hi everyone my name's Tamara chambers
[Laughter]
carbon-copy a soulless garbage are you
Brad yeah what is your scary voice we
just went and saw us
we did a non-spoiler review on Brad's
channel and this is a spoiler review so
go watch that yes really good this one
is gonna be full of spoilers so click
away if you haven't seen it I totally
recommend seeing it before having it
being spoiled like most things - first
thoughts about the movie is before we
get into crazy spoilers it was amazing
know the movie was great
I loved it mmm because we're going into
a spoiler talk about the movie like it
only in the sense it like it almost
feels like if you were to go into a
spoiler talk like 30 minutes after
seeing the shine there's there's things
I could talk about but I like need to do
my research
yeah I yeah I don't even know where to
start on spoilers because there's one
big reveal at the end there is which can
be argued that it was a pretty very
well-done but obvious reveal it uh-huh
you could argue that it was like
obviously leading up to this thing and
it was done very well it was a thing
that like it made other things that
happened before it makes sense pieces
together some things yeah where it's I
mean I guess we could spoil it that it
turns out one of them in the family
mother in the family is one of the
carbon copies of the people from the
beginning of the movie where you see
that she saw one as a young girl in a
funhouse and certain things that she had
done throughout the movie like you'd
maybe sit there and go like I don't know
if I would do that right then when
that's revealed it suddenly makes all
that other stuff make sense
so I was saying in the other episode
Jordan Peele has this interview where he
was like you know I didn't have horror
movies that were full of black people I
didn't have horror movies that were full
of people who looked like me and also I
didn't have horror movies where people
just made the right decisions and I
thought that on that a lot and there was
just one moment where I was like well
I'm gonna argue that Jordan Peele
because she goes into the funhouse she
sees the man holding hands and she walks
into the funhouse and I'm like why go
back to your family
what are you doing here go back and then
if he I mean it makes total sense that
she's the copy and so she goes she's
going down there to find the real one
who has been the copy this whole time
it's so well done I think it it really
pieces some things together that are
already made sense for the most part in
them and then for them to even make more
sense it's so exciting it's like that
movie that you go and you see and you're
like yeah that made plenty of sense but
I have to see it again because then it's
gonna make even more sense yeah I mean I
remember Hands Across America so I'm
like you know what I was probably
hanging out in a funhouse during that
all and that was all going on that's the
thing about this movie because from the
very beginning of it I was like this was
gonna be wildly unpredictable like I
don't know where this story is gonna
lead when you see the trailer and then
the movie starts with a blurb at the
beginning of it that's saying like there
are many underground Subway's that
haven't been visited in years I'm like I
have no idea where this movie is going
to why are you telling us this
information and you would never know
from the trailer that that it's like
this is a horror movie that
inspired off of the Hands Across America
event from 1986 and it does it it does
it so like it's a good surprise like
I've seen I'm going to see movies before
where they throw something at you
that isn't even hinted at in the trailer
and it just comes across where I mean
both of us saw serenity right and
acrimony like I want to go see acrimony
where the trailer is the trailer is like
Oh taraji be Henson's husband's cheating
on her she wants a revenge you go see
the movie and it's like you would never
know this movie has a sci-fi subplot
about a guy building a battery and
trying to sell it like this this was
done well cuz a lot of it sort of is is
really inspired off of his hands across
America thing that happened in 1986 yeah
and the way that it's tight in is is
creepy like the imagery that you get
from it where they're all these clones
holding hands I'm watching it thinking
in my head like well I guess that I
guess like Hands Across America
apparently it worked out to get like to
get us all to join hands and I'll get
along we just had to be cloned and the
clones had to destroy right it's like
Hands Across America is like a slasher
movie version of the flood from the
Bible you see you know wipe things out
yeah replace it with these zombies going
around with scissors I mean I I am
really bad at picking up on things yeah
in movies I never guess the ending of
things and when she started going down
the stairs into the tunnel I was like
the beginning that thing they told us in
the beginning that's where this and I'm
sure everyone already knew where it was
going but I was like amazing crazy this
is so good it unraveled so well I think
I it's been a long time since I've been
so thrilled about a war movie yeah and I
got I loved it I loved the twist the end
I loved the reveal I loved how they
ended it on just such a we made it yeah
but also by the way there's more
it just got it was so good everything
was so unnerving the voices yeah of the
others were so good and so scary you
said this in the other would I have even
that frightened by a voice every oh yeah
and the acting was amazing and they just
they did a killer job leading up to the
twist at the end and whether people like
that or think it was obvious or whatever
you want to think about it I think it
was just done so well yeah I thought it
was done well I I could I could see
where someone might see it coming
totally and when it happened in the
movie it might have been a passing
thought in my head early on in the film
but nothing I really thought that hard
about really so when it happened I it
wasn't so much I was sitting there like
holy like or anything like that it
mean it was more like oh oh okay that
make sense given everything that we had
seen beforehand it makes sense that this
is how this movie ended I thought about
it at the very very end the dads in the
car and he like adjusts his glasses and
at one point the clone takes the glasses
from him and I was like oh are they
saying that the dad is now the clone
like they got switched somehow is that
what they're doing and then immediately
after it was revealed that it was the
moms character and so for a moment I was
like well does that mean we don't know
who is and who isn't they're just being
very clear about the mom and like maybe
a couple of them are the clothes and
they don't think it's the case but I
love that it's kind of open-ended like
that yeah I think a lot of people might
wish that all of it was open-ended like
that like it's British year that the mom
was because they showed oh yeah yeah but
I think if there's any kind of upsetness
about this movie it'll be that like it
wasn't open-ended enough sure I don't
feel that way
it feels like it's neither do I cuz I
don't know why really a lot of this
stuff is going on
like what started this whole like they
tell you nothing yeah it kind of admired
that about the movie like yeah I don't
like it it does set it up like it's
something you could build upon if you
wanted to add more to this universe
afterward and if you did it would
probably be really cool if not hey why
not like che yeah I mean it gives me a
little bit of information it's one of
those where it's like if all the
information was given to me about where
these people came from it would have
been cheaper too boring yeah it was
perfect amount of information we knew
that they were there and that was enough
kind of deals yeah cuz there's real
there wasn't really anyone there who
would be able to even tell us where it
went on for me because it ends like with
all these people are holding hands
across these mountains and everything it
did look like a situation that could
probably be fixed pretty quick like
music and then helicopters over them
yeah the mountains like they have
expanded there's a lot of people because
everyone in the world yeah you're like
well what's the next step it seems
hopeful though it does cuz I mean
they're just kind of attacking people
with scissors it's like really really
they're lucky they killed as many people
as they did cuz yeah though they're just
kind of going around like just chasing
people with scissors like that this
situations gonna fix itself after the
woefully unprepared are gonna die but
everyone else is gonna be probably fine
yeah yeah like any kind of massive
weapon could take out this line of
people who are waiting to die yeah yeah
yeah it was scary enough in the moment
and then afterwards you're like I said I
feel hopeful yeah which is the perfect
tone will never try hands across America
hands across America gets sued by
everyone
it's like watching a horror movie
inspired off of the we are the world
[Laughter]
right a horror movie version of comic
relief
[Laughter]
oh yeah the the pets at Sarah McLachlan
video that's but it might as well be
that that dogs journey they got coming
out in a few weeks
guys I've been looking forward to this
[Laughter]
go see the movie don't drink too much
before hands and enjoy it it was amazing
no I highly recommend it it was a lot of
fun yeah thank you so much for joining
me
go watch the spoiler free I think we
went into some really cool details in
that way um thank you for watching see
you guys next week
[Music]